welcome welcome to the class day award
ceremony celebrating the achievements of
the members of the class of 2011 of the
College of Dental Medicine I would like
to welcome dr. William Kalman who is
over here president-elect of the
American Dental Association welcome to
our ceremonies that the calendar will be
our guest speaker at graduation
exercises tomorrow I'd like to thank
Delta Dental the representatives from
delta dental and the eastern dennis
dentist insurance corporation for
sponsoring this event and the reception
that follows i would like to thank the
New York State Dental Association
represented by dr. Jeffrey senza for
helping us and giving out the the
souvenirs the woody a Coulomb Jeffrey
favors the favorites dr. Center is going
to do you a favor when this is over and
and dr. sensor will make a few remarks
on behalf of the Dental Association a
little later this afternoon's program is
unique for the dental school we haven't
always done it we've done it for the
past few years and it's a marvelous
display of the intellectual diversity
that is the College of Dental Medicine
we have basic scientists we have
clinicians we have researchers we have
people in public health and God knows
what goes on in the halls and Cardinals
I don't even want to ask but there's a
tremendous diversity of experience that
exists here for the students I want to
thank our faculty who did so much to
inspire and to engage our students
there's no time in life that is quite
like going through dental school I think
our students will agree and your
Bittman to the classroom and the clinic
enhances that learning experience for
all of our students thank you I want to
thank the parents and family who are
here this afternoon because they are the
source of love and encouragement that
makes this celebration possum no one is
prouder as dr. baldt you said today no
one is prouder of our students than
their families even though sometimes
it's misplaced sometimes it's
exaggerated but no one is prouder of you
guys than your families the students
that we honor this afternoon actually
honor us with their love of learning you
continually amaze us with your academic
accomplishments it's very difficult for
those people who are not directly
involved in dental education to realize
how many challenges there are to
complete it successfully is difficult to
complete it with honors is really
impressive the key is persistence and
determination nothing in the world can
take the place of persistence and
determination talent alone will not
education alone will not the world is
full of talented educated derelicts
persistence and determination are the
vital ingredients and that is what these
people have added to the mix and we are
happy to have them as part of our family
I want to thank Dean Lamster too
encourages all of us to innovate and
take risks no progress can be made
without taking risks he once told me
that if no one took risks Michelangelo
would have painted the sistine floor
there is no risk at all in introducing
to bring us greetings our dean dr. IRB
lapsed
thank you I there's sort of a running
joke here at the school that I spent a
good deal of my time ringing greetings
and thanks but certainly the person or
the entity that we need to thank today
is Mother Nature because if you followed
the weather reports over the cost of the
previous three days we were supposed to
experience the deluge today between
ten-thirty and 12 and we did not so
that's a marvelous thing for all of us
and we offer a round of applause from
other nature at this time of year the
academic calendar is filled with
terrific events most notable among them
is graduation which is a rite of passage
at the College of Dental Medicine this
has traditionally been divided up into
two parts the university graduation
today and then our College of Dental
Medicine graduation which will be
tomorrow at ten-thirty both events
celebrating collective achievement
because you are the class of 2011 he
will always be known as the class of
2011 this is the third year however that
we have held a new ceremony and dr.
liquid alluded to this arc lasting which
recognizes individual achievement so we
recognize you collectively we also
recognize you individual the curriculum
at CDM is demanding and the individuals
that will be called to the podium today
of being recognized for the individual
outstanding achievements I want to cook
gradually each member of the class of
20,000 2011 who's being so on our
students are a great resource for us and
if we don't say that enough I think it's
important for me to emphasize that once
again and excuse me we acknowledge them
collectively and individually and they
make us a better place they really do
make us a better place there are certain
times in your life the certain events in
your life I think that you remember
always the events are earlier today the
events of this afternoon and the events
tomorrow will be those times we
congratulate you on your accomplishments
and we wish
only the best thank you
it is my pleasure to call up next our
vice dean for academic affairs who
really makes a great much of this place
work dr. Lenny Moss Valentine thank you
thank you dr. Liston tell dear
colleagues guests and new doctors I say
that's very loudly new doctors you are
really new doctors this is a happy day
for all of us for the graduates for the
family and friends but also for us for
the Faculty of the College of Dental
Medicine on this day I want to join in
congratulating all of you as you already
have been congratulated by the Dean most
of you arrived here four years ago and
at that time celebrated the white coat
ceremony today you have earned the title
of doctor the for intervening years have
been challenging this is not an easy
curriculum it's not only for you but for
the faculty as well each new class
presents with its own unique profile of
individuals but somehow in four years
you become family there has been a
mounted of course work and extensive
preclinical and clinical training to
prepare you for your professional
responsibilities you've worked hard and
now is the time to enjoy your
achievements we are very happy to check
to sharing that joy
now making opening remarks and
representing the class to tell you how
important she is she has four names you
really have to be important to have four
days dr. Renee Christine Pompey Reynolds
representative class of two thousand
thank you doctor licked involved Dean
Lamster dr. Santine I am extremely
honored to be here representing the
class of 2011 and speaking to their
family today so today is class day and
we're here to celebrate the many
accomplishments of the unique
individuals that make up our class and
make it a very distinguished class when
we first met four years ago we were
quite a motley crew coming from all over
the world from places like Armenia
Nigeria Nicaragua Korea and even Queens
we were in various stages of our young
adult lives with ages spanning 20 years
the youngest of us was barely 20 the
oldest almost 40 some of us had known
since kindergarten that we were going to
be doctors and we followed on the path
without wavering some of us had watched
our parents who were dentists and
physicians and knew that destiny was our
destiny was to be to follow in their
footsteps and by the same token some of
us were the first people to graduate
from college in our families and other
of us took more circuitous routes and
worked in different careers before
coming to demo school regardless we are
all very accomplished individuals before
we started some of us had already earned
master's degrees three of us were
dentists and other countries and now we
all share this very special bond of
being professional colleagues who have
shared the same experience at Columbia
we all know what it's like to dissect a
cadaver extract a tooth for the same
time for the first time survive one of
dr. hi doggies very difficult practicals
or past the most challenging of courses
like health promotion
according to my tally as dental students
we took 25 practicals 36 skills
assessments at least 75 quizzes and 82
long arduous written exams this is all
in addition to the other
responsibilities we had other
assignments papers presentations this my
friends as you know is no small task
together we've studied sometimes not as
much as we should have we've laughed and
we've cried tears of frustration
sometimes more times than we'd like to
admit so on milestone occasions like
today people like to say wow time flies
seems just like yesterday that seems
just like yesterday that we were taking
the DAT or it seems just like yesterday
that we opened that letter from Columbia
saying that we had been admitted here
and to me I think that it's it seems
like a lifetime and and not just
yesterday the past four years of dental
school might have been just a blip in
our hopefully long and prosperous lives
but in that time we've undergone an
identity changing irreversible
transformation from a layperson to a
doctor the caretaker of health and
well-being and health including oral
health is the most precious treasure
that anybody can possess it's a
prerequisite to enjoying everything else
in life this transformation to a dentist
a doctor is really incomparable to any
other life change perhaps other than
becoming a parent and by the way 16 of
us became parents while we were in
dental school kudos to you guys I don't
know how you did it speaking of
extracurricular endeavors while enduring
this endured while enduring this
rigorous curriculum we should be proud
that we collectively as a class advanced
a profession and served others through
our involvement in clubs through
research pursuits and through global
health mission trips additionally 17 of
us found time to get married some ran
marathons some were in dual degree
programs that the teachers college and
even one of us was a four-time
consecutive free weight club
and it doesn't stop there are many of us
will go on to receive additional
master's degrees and at least four of us
are going to go on to receive md's as
oral surgeons so in the past few days
there's been a lot of buzz about how
excited we are that we're all going to
be called doctors soon and doctor is
really one of the most prestigious
titles anyone can earn of course this is
exciting but it's also very very grave
it means that people will assume all
kinds of things about us before they
even know who we are and that will
constantly be striving to live up to the
expectations that come with the title
tomorrow's after years of perseverance
we will receive a diploma that says
Doctor of Dental Surgery but every day
after that we must continue to work to
deserve the designation it is a tall
order it seems exhausting sometimes to
think of how unceasingly diligent we
must be to keep up with our skills our
knowledge of new materials pharmacology
medical advances our patients and the
public expected of us but every time we
feel overwhelmed by the need to continue
cramming more facts into our heads we
must face these apprehensions armed with
the memories of our past triumphs in the
end we ultimately all got by with sheer
determination just like dr. lick inflict
and fall said encouragement from family
patients faculty loads of caffeine and
with a little help from our friends I
think most of our my classmates would
agree that we couldn't have survived
dental school without the informal
education we received from each other it
was invaluable having classmates around
to critique us in creek art in pre
clinic in our endo fills and our amalgam
carvings we all shared notes and tables
and websites and resources as we
laboured to memorize hundreds of
pathological lesions and drugs and
diseases once we made it to seeing live
patients we consulted with each other
poring over radiographs and mounted
diagnostic models trying to come up with
the best treatment plan one day many
years from now we'll be far far removed
from our preclinical days
when it took three tubs of alginate
before we could get a decent diagnostic
impression on our type Adan or it took
us three hours to board or mold one
custom tray or we could barely get
through perio charting in three hours
many of us will be working in our own
private offices contentedly reaping the
rewards of our hard work although
individual success like this is what our
mentors and our parents and we rightly
hope for ourselves we must avoid
professional isolation graduation marks
the culmination of our formal training
but today on class day let us commit to
continuing this collaboration with each
other that was so intimate instrumental
to our success here at Columbia we
should all sign up for study groups take
leadership positions in dental societies
be a mentor to a young person
considering a dental profession and yes
give of our precious time to teach in
these times of easy communication we
have no excuse to lose touch we as are
we as a class our own greatest
professional resource we did not achieve
excellence alone in academia and we will
not achieve it alone in the professional
world wise old Benjamin Franklin said an
investment in knowledge pays the best
interest as we reflect upon graduation
and the investment of time and effort
and sweat and tears and yes of course
tuition money it took to get here we
should consider ourselves very blessed
that we had this opportunity I don't
know if you remember four years ago at
the white coat ceremony dr. McManus told
us the story about how he came to learn
of the cost of new york city taxi
medallion and he told the story about
how he had a conversation with a cab
driver who was so happy because he had
finally collected the money that it took
to buy a medallion and shockingly they
cost almost four hundred thousand
dollars and these medallions are so
valuable because they offer a license to
make a stable livelihood as a cab driver
in one of the greatest cities of the
world and we've made a similar
investment in our education only the
license feel receive marks us the
keepers of knowledge valuable to every
human being
it's a beautiful profession that marries
art and science and technology and
crafts and human interaction it will
give us great career independence as
well as the satisfaction of helping
other people along the way we've done
well to invest in knowledge and we must
continue reinvesting in it through the
years ahead so that we can continually
be worthy of the title doctor so class
of 2011 it has been a long road and
we've gotten here by putting one foot in
front of the other we gave a helping
hand when a friend needed it or maybe
just some well written notes we sought
advice from our most trusted faculty we
learned how to be compassionate within
our patients were in pain be thorough in
our examinations and how to stay cool
when things didn't go as planned or at
least for working on it everything we
really need to know for long successful
careers we learned in dental school
whatever the next challenge is being
residency or finding an associate chip
or opening our own practice all while
balancing duties to society as doctors
and to our friends and families we'll
get through it just fine we've done it
before we can do it again
congratulations my outstanding
classmates faculty I hope we make you
proud and families the free dental care
starts today
Thank You Renee for those of you came in
too late I'm gonna repeat my opening
remarks no just kidding now we get to
the business at hand the business that
all of us came here for to honor those
with exceptional achievement over these
past four years our first presenter for
the highest academic achievement award
dr. Letty more salad
alright you just saw me I just mentioned
that there had been a mountain of
coursework and extensive preclinical and
clinical training in the past four years
it is difficult to perform
satisfactorily throughout such a long
period that our ups and downs in our
lives which tend to be reflected in our
performance it's even more difficult to
perform well consistently at the top of
the class for four years it's such a
performance I now wish to recognize with
the highest academic achievement award
to dr. Kelley Fleming walk
to present the new york academy of
dentistry exemplary Professional Conduct
award dr. jonathan roberts president in
new york academy of dentistry done
greetings for those of you who don't
know the new york academy of dentistry
is an organization dedicated to the
enhancement of the dental profession
through the promotion of the highest
standards in education clinical practice
and ethical conduct hopefully some of
you in the audience will eventually
become members of our esteemed Academy
it is my pleasure as president of New
York Academy of nasterie to prevent to
present our award to petrol attention
photo op John
to present the delta dental student
leadership award i call on dr. cheryl
learner dental director for the
mid-atlantic region and dr. abba mill
his lair director of sales for a dental
death thank you very much and
congratulations class of 2011 I was
asked to keep my words brief because
there are a lot of awards and a lot of
very important people here today so I
just wanted to remind you if you didn't
already know that a license is a
privilege and you want to make sure to
honor that privilege and honor your
education by giving back to the
community and that's what the Delta
Dental leadership award is all about I
have a plaque in my office that I keep
up there and look at it to remind myself
every day that says dentists make the
world smile and that's what I know
you're all going to do so I'd like to
present the following for students a
certificate for the Delta Dental
leadership award along with the check
for twenty-five hundred dollars to
Andrew W Boyd dr. Andrew W boy excuse me
to dr. June ynez hair would
dr. poor windy hockey
and dr. Kelley Fleming walk
congratulations
come in tomorrow
you
to present the next series in Awards
there is several that our Dean is going
to present among them ella marie you'll
award College of Dental Medicine
Leadership Award to research excellence
award announced the winners of the
Omicron kappa epsilon key and the
pursuit to philip scholars as well as
New York State Dental Foundation dean's
award our dean dr. i relapsed ER i have
the privilege of presenting the next
series of awards six in fact and again
my congratulations to to all here today
first the ella marie you will award is
given for distinguished service to
fellow students and really a commitment
to the entire student body this year our
awardee is a third-generation CDM
graduate his grandfather was a graduate
his uncle is a graduate and he and his
brother are our graduates and it's
really a pleasure for me to reward this
to dr. andrew boyd
the culture dental medicine leadership
award is given through somebody who
really embodies the characteristics of
leadership and the person who's
receiving this award has been
characterized as displaying mature
leadership she had a commitment to
international oral health through a trip
to Guatemala she's a published author a
person of the highest integrity and
personal characteristics and again a
pleasure for me to present this to dr.
Jacqueline haga
the research excellent Excellence Award
is selected by our research committee in
this year the honoree is dr. eric frank
eric is staying with us next year to
join our orthodontic program his
research was conducted in Germany mouths
lab and his specific topic was on stem
cell homing
the next award are to those students who
were inducted into okay you which is the
dental Honor Society approximately ten
to twelve percent of the class each year
is inducted and those individuals were
honored at us at a dinner that we had
was held in the early spring I'm going
to announce their names and I asked them
to stand they don't have to come up here
dr. Andrew void dr. Andrew Fisher
dr. amalia he gets young
dr. Renee de kolinsky
dr. ankle Ingram
that's a petrol my fishing
dr. in a 15 campaign Reynolds
and I should tell you swimming
congratulations for them all the next
award is the is for the PT Philip
scholarship and again these students
receive their reward actually in the
fall at a two-day ceremony eight members
of the class were asked to come and
interview members of the college level
medicine faculty as well as the New York
State Dental Association interviewed the
eight the each were selected to be
interviewed for various reasons
strengths that they displayed and the
two winners this year were June dr. June
Inez heroin june and dr. Kelley Fleming
walk
congratulations
the last award that I've been a bestow
this afternoon is the only war that we
give in this ceremony to a third year
student and it's the new york state
dental foundation dean's award as you
can see in the program it's awarded to a
third year student for academic
accomplishment committed service as well
as membership in the American student
Dental Association the individual is so
selected has been class president for
the last three years the current three
years and really has an outstanding
academic record this comes along with
not only an opportunity for a picture
with me but also with a with a plaque
and a check for five thousand dollars
and so pleasure for me to award this to
Aaron Myers
I would like to call it this time dr.
Jeffrey sensor to come up and say a few
words to us on behalf of the New York
State Dental Association Jeffrey thank
you Richard I will keep this very very
brief dr. lickin Thal alluded to the
term favors and you will all be
receiving a favor from the New York
State Dental Association it's not the
favor itself but what we really want
from you and that is to become active in
the tripartite I'm sure you all know
about the 88th American Dental
Association but most of you are unaware
that this is the father if you will
society or the overall society that we
are involved in but there is also at the
state level in for New York the New York
State Dental Association and then in New
York State for instance there are 13
local component societies and I am
president-elect of the New York County
dental society which involves Manhattan
I will invite and really plead with all
of you as new doctors to become active I
don't want to steal dr. Calhoun's famous
lines that only a dentist and this is
what got him in my opinion to his
position as future president next year
of the American Dental Association but
only a dentist really should be making
certain decisions not only for your
patience as you see them in the chair
but involving politics this is a very
very big important part of your
profession so please become active in
the tripartite you will find all of you
are computer savvy go on the website
join as soon
student members but when you leave here
join the tripartite thank you and now to
prevent it did I say okay you said it
yeah that's that's what you do to
present the divisional Excellence Award
behavioral science dr. Martin Davis good
afternoon I haven't had a chance yet but
congratulations it's been an interesting
for years hasn't it you have been a
class of whom we are particularly proud
and I've heard that time and again from
many faculty there are two corrections I
have one the actual taxi medallion rate
these days I found out recently as a
million dollars none of you are carrying
that kind of debt that's good and it's a
far more interesting job I promise you
but let's go on to this award which a
doctor temper asked me to present and it
goes to someone who I've seen in her
office going in and out early in the
mornin late in the evening working very
hard and someone who manifest much of
what behavioral science is about a
kinder gentler person but someone who
cares more works harder would be hard to
find I'm very proud to present the award
and the behavioral sciences divisional
excellence to rapala Shaw
and now to prevent the divisional
excellence award in community health and
the american association of public
health dentistry award dr. david albert
director of the division of community
health strings Nina you know for
community health and public health this
is a remarkable class really cognizant
of the population-based health in a way
that I've never experienced here at
Columbia and a pleasure to work with
this class the first awardee from our
section and my division is Stacy
Robinson stacy is receiving the
divisional excellence award in community
health Stacy was a remarkable student
involved in almost everything at this
dental school but in addition to that
worked with us on a project that
expanded the boundaries of public health
looking at tobacco cessation and did a
project examining what was going on at
dental schools across the country she's
a remarkable job and was able to get a
100-percent response rate we have
presented that in several national
meeting stacey has earned honors for
that and we are putting together a
publication on that Stacy
our next awardee for the american
association of public health industry
award June harewood June was one of our
/ cece Phillips scholars to share along
with Kelley Fleming their work was
remarkable it was an absolute pleasure i
worked with about 12 different pairs of
students over the past 20 years here at
columbia and / CT phillips programs this
was the most remarkable june's
understanding of the health care reform
laws and policies was remarkable she
then took what she presented in her CT
Phillips and presented it in my course
in all health care delivery to the
students in the class along with Kelly
the presentation was remarkable our
understanding our ability to assimilate
it and then present it back to the
students in the second in the third year
class I'm sorry was absolutely
remarkable was a pleasure to work with
you
endodontics as everybody got their
points today to present the divisional
Excellence Award and endodontics and the
American Association of endodontists
award dr. Jack levy socio-economic
professor of endodontics I'm deeply
honored to have been given the chance to
be associated with Columbia University
College of Dental Medicine for more than
a quarter of a century of which was
spent with the area of endodontic
concentration this year marks the
culmination of that program two students
from the area of endodontic
concentration were selected to receive
the endodontic Award for Excellence in
endodontics petrol magician and sidekick
saying the area of concentration has
inspired students to for a love of the
specialty in endodontics as well as
created novel research topics which
enable them to get an experience in
dental research their research results
were published in the Jarvey Journal of
the William Jarvis a society from 2003
to 2010 there were two research report
reports published per year petrol and
sigh had their research published in
2010 throughout the years students were
motivated to attend the New Jersey
Dental Association's there and the
annual meeting and present table clinic
presentations sigh Kip saying presented
his research at the 2010 meeting this
was a first time experience to
participate in an organized dental
meeting before graduating
dental school there is a saying which
reads friends are flowers in life's
garden may we continue our academic
friendships stay connected with our alma
mater and try to come back to share your
talents with Columbia's of educational
endeavors good love good health and
happiness in your chosen profession on
behalf of the Department of endodontics
I'm pleased to award to present these
awards for excellence in root canal
therapy the Columbia University College
of Dental Medicine divisional excellence
in endodontics goes to Petro mitesh in
the american association of endodontist
student achievement award in endodontics
goes to side kid saying
the awards for excellence in operative
dentistry and related topics is going to
be presented by the gentleman who taught
them the beginnings of operative
dentistry and made them toe the line and
taught them organization and all the
things that they have carried into the
clinic and will carry forward my
pleasure to introduce dr. professor of
restorative dentistry dr. Farhad avi
let me tell you something
I am so sorry I'm just over here to
apologize making it to work so hard I
didn't know one day or become like me
it's really an honor to be here and give
these awards to our DS and then so happy
to see you all of you and don't forget
whatever I did was out of love nothing
personal now can I go through them yes
oh so difficult with the abort the first
award goes to dr. petrol machine
don't move I wasn't kidding how many
hours we just dr. machine
cetera dr. pattern
Christopher sure dr. christopher's xie
don't go anywhere still you american
academy of cosmetic days American
Academy a cosmetic award goes again to
the doctor yeah
American Academy of implant dentistry
award goes to dr. Ronnie water
American Academy of osseointegration
award goes to dr. david p no
College of Dental Medicine dental
practice administration award goes to
dr. Kapoor
I'm never lool
Contessa's a ward of clinical
achievement in the storage dentistry
goes to dr. Leah's vanilla
call dr. Lenny mas Alan teen to give the
divisional excellence award in oral
biology and the American Association of
oral biologists award the faculty of the
division of oral biology teaches quite a
series of course is doing the first and
second years there was a while ago and
I'm not sure he's still remembering but
we remember and we remember those who
did very well in particularly and today
recognizing two individuals the first
individual is dr. Jung enjoy who will
receive the divisional excellence award
for oral biology
I am equally pleased to present the
second award the American Association of
oral biologists award to dr. Gorrie
valker
I mean reduction they sit down to like
all right are you here already stay here
oral surgeons don't be like that to give
the divisional excellence and assorted
awards for all the maxillofacial surgery
this gentleman dr. Sidney Isaac chairman
of the section of hospital dentistry and
director of the oral and maxillofacial
surgery
thank you so since everyone was nice and
short I'll be nice and long it gives me
great pleasure to present the next
series of awards while some of the stoop
while some of you students were sleeping
those who won the awards related to oral
and maxillofacial surgery might have
been in the operating room late at night
with my residents were making morning
rounds at six thirty seven o'clock in
the morning participated in the aoc one
of the award winners actually did two
aocs one in orthodontics and one and one
electively without a grade in oral and
maxillofacial surgery so it's a real
pleasure to give these awards and one
person who I really want to thank is dr.
Lu Mandel who oversees the second third
year courses in oral maxillofacial
surgery and really says serves as a
mentor to the students so
and I also want to thank dr. Jennifer
Beshore for helping select the awards
pertaining to oral pain and sedation so
the first winner if you will is dr.
Renata kelem ski who will be given the
divisional excellence award in oral and
maxillofacial surgery and she'll be
doing a residency at Albert Einstein
College of Medicine
the next award is going is coming from
the American Academy of craniofacial
pain and it's to marry dr. Mary cheatham
who i believe is doing a general
practice residency program right and
there's a check my pleasure the next
award is the American Association of
oral and maxillofacial surgeons award
and this goes to dr. michael wang will
be doing a residency at university of
north carolina i think michael scrubbed
in on more of my cases than i even did
and it's a real pleasure to give him
this award
keep them here yeah well this is that
award
stay there monster bite see we tore him
to listen well the next award is from
the American Dental Society of
anesthesiology is the Horace wells award
in oral and maxillofacial surgery again
it's going to Michael
the next award goes to dr. Michelle
kroenke oh who is receiving the American
Association of oral and maxillofacial
surgeons dental implant award and
Michelle is going to be staying on with
us for six years of pain and suffering
in my residency program
and the last award goes to dr. Laura and
mithoon who is receiving the New York
State Society Award and she'll be doing
a residency with my friends at the
University of Michigan
that's it reckon he said something to
thank you very cuz you're representing
the section for dr. pappano dr. dana
wolf who's director of the predoctoral
periodontics program will present the
divisional excellence awards and oral
radiology and the American Academy of
oral maxillofacial radiology very quick
congratulations to all the graduates and
your families just imagine that I am dr.
singer right now the divisional
excellence award in oral radiology goes
to rupali
ow
how about this one very nice one and the
American Academy of oral and
maxillofacial radiology award goes to
glory le
dr. wolf promised me that she was going
to do something humorous when she came
up and she was true to her word to give
the divisional Excellence Award northa
Daleks and the american association of
orthodontists award dr. satish pie it's
a great honor to give their ward for the
division of orthodontics the first award
would be four divisional excellence in
orthodontics Amalia giggity L
I think the next award is the american
association of orthodontists award goes
to running Reynolds
now we get to the little people the
divisional Excellence Award in pediatric
dentistry the American Academy of
pediatric dentistry Oh award will be
presented by dr. shantanu lau director
of predoctoral pediatric dentistry dr
lal good evening graduates and families
this has been an exceptional year in
pediatric dentistry is a year marked by
hard work outstanding grades a
near-perfect match result and an
opportunity to provide quality care to
all children ranging from the
underserved children in our populations
in our clinics to the unserved children
around the world you have shown kindness
and love clinical proficiency and
professionalism and we honor you all
however a few names bear special mention
for the divisional Excellence Award
please recognize dr. Amalia agita
and for the prestigious American Academy
of pediatric dentistry award please
recognize dr. Kelley Fleming walk who
will be staying on another two years in
our residency program
we'll ask dr. dana wolf to come up again
to give out the awards in periodontics
there are three event the divisional
excellence award in periodontics it's my
pleasure to award to IVA Leroy
the American Academy of periodontology
award is awarded to dr. univ value yeah
the quintessence award for clinical
achievement in periodontics goes to
amalia it gets young
it's like to call dr. George Shelby
white director division of
prosthodontics to give out the multiple
awards in prosthodontics dr. white I
would like to congratulate all of you
today I know it's a very special day for
you and I again want to apologize to you
for the division of prosthodontics
placing you through so much aggravation
in these last four years but you all did
well and I like to graduate you on your
your merits i would like to present the
divisional excellence award and
prosthodontics to pho of Sicily
next I would like to present the handout
best of the best pasta to you Anika
lindgren
i would like to present the
international congress of oral and
planetologist to sandra mbb
i would like to present the new york
academy of oral rehabilitation awards in
removable prosthetics to give petrol
yeah the last or would be the new york
academy of war real babe oral
rehabilitation Eugene Rothchild memorial
award in fixed prosthodontics to Marvin
abarca
petros gonna need a wheelbarrow to get I
just want to do it once that throw my
decision is says they're prepared the
divisional excellence award in
stomatology in the American Academy of
oral maxillofacial pathology award in
America academy of oral medicine award
was presented by dr. Elizabeth Filippone
assistant professor of law pathology
congratulations saw the graduates the
divisional excellence award in
stomatology goes to Kelley Fleming walk
and the American Academy of oral
maxillofacial pathology award goes to
linelu in emmett ova
and Academy American Academy of oral
medicine award goes to andrew boyd
the quintessence award for research
achievement would be presented by dr.
Carol Coons el director of clinical
research
hi everyone let me add my
congratulations to the many that you
have received already very well done and
much deserved I am here to recognize and
honor the recipient of the quintus
quintessence award for research
achievement the recipient of this year's
award is leora Walter
I'd like to say just a little bit about
Lee auras accomplishment she is only the
second dental student ever to receive a
National Institutes of Health Fogarty
International clinical research
scholarship she used yes that's that's
five accomplishment she used her reward
to conduct an epidemiological study in
Lima Peru on trends and head and neck
cancer and during that year of her
experience in Peru she was in fact the
only dental student of the 88 Fogarty
supported trainees during that
particular year so leora again my great
pleasure to present you with this award
and to wish you well in your future
endeavors
dr. Kunze l will also present the
association of women dentists award so
I'm very happy to be given the
opportunity to present two awards today
and let me announce and honor the
recipient of the a AWD standing for
American Association of Women dentists
award the recipient of this year's award
is Mary Beth cheatham
this award was established to recognize
a senior dental student to is both an a
AWD member and has demonstrated
outstanding leadership and academic
excellence certainly these are qualities
much possessed by Mary Beth who has had
a very active career here at the dental
school as a member of many professional
student organizations and has having
been very involved in many facets of
community service in addition she has
maintained a very strong academic record
receiving letters of commendation every
year us that she has been here at the
College of Dental Medicine clearly you
meet the criteria of excellence in
academics leadership and professionalism
and it's not hard to present you with
this award
dr. Davis will present three awards for
awards coming to you never looks like
four to be 40 was not I said he can take
over from here dr. David thank you
doctor looked at all the first ward I
have the pleasure of presenting this is
someone who has worked very long very
hard for all of us in one sense or
another as you know there is the mother
church I tend to think with that way
rather the father church there is the
American Dental Association that doctor
sends are mentioned to you as you all
know by the way if you join now it is
less expensive than if you lose your
membership so don't let that happen but
there is an American student Dental
Association which represented all of you
and the national president of that
organization is today receiving the
award of excellence from the American
student Dental Association it is my
pleasure to produce for you today on
this very stage the national president
of Asda dr. Corwin hockey
yes I'm also pleased this next
presentation is on behalf of the
International College of dentists again
an organization which is meant to honor
dentists who have gone out of their way
in our profession on behalf of others on
behalf of the profession itself as well
this recognises a leadership it is my
pleasure to have dr. Chad already come
up the class president to receive this
award
as many of you will remember one of the
first people to be concerned with oral
health in the modern world was dr.
Pierre foo chard there is an Academy
again an honorary organization in his
name that organization is celebrating
its 75th anniversary this year they were
founded in nineteen thirty-six if you
can stay with me in the higher math but
they tried to recognize outstanding
academic achievement and this award for
just debt I pleased to present to do
kyung kim
the second award from the pier fish art
academy is presented to Jennifer Park
and the third prf Rashard recognition of
academic excellence award goes to Andy
one
when to announce one were award that was
already presented but I would think it's
worthy of recognition again during this
ceremony one of our now deceased former
chairs of oral and maxillofacial surgery
was George of intervene e-man done for
his intellect his wit and his general
caring nature the award in his name this
year was given to and if you'll stand
please andrew boyd
there are I think listed in your
programs third year awards of
achievement achievement that were
presented during the third year we want
to recognize those students I don't know
if they're here tonight Mona dunashie
Jennifer Wilbur Andrew boy Renata kelem
ski Corwin hockey Jung and joy and
Kelley Fleming walk stand if you hear
now it is my great pleasure to present
one of my favorite faculty people and
obviously one of the students favorite
faculty people as well and well chosen
dr. Graham received her DVS from this
institution in aught five I believe then
joined our then did a general practice
residency then joined our faculty Todd
received her master's degree from the
Columbia Teachers College and today
tomorrow next year when you're going to
get that PhD last year
received did you march in the parade and
everything you got that okay this one be
sure that you got you do dds MS PhD
all-around wonderful teacher near pier
for the students beloved by the students
and me dr. Rose anagram
it warms my heart to be here with you on
this special day when you look back on
this day years from now you will
remember how you felt and I hope you
feel wonderful right now because you
have accomplished something
extraordinary words cannot describe the
academic challenge you have just
conquered you are part of a select group
of people that know what it means to be
called a graduate of the College of
Dental Medicine as you go out into the
world you will find every sacrifice you
made was worth it and the education you
received here is the best there is and
it will serve you well I am so glad to
see you here with the loved ones that
have supported you over the past four
years you are so successful and
accomplished in large part because of
the people that guided you and stood by
you through the most difficult times you
had people that believed in you and I
believed in you and I can tell you today
that belief was well placed four years
have passed since I met you on your
first day of class in the pre clinic on
that day you did not know me and I did
not know you but I have come to know you
all so very well I have learned about
each of your different personalities and
what warm witty and intelligent people
you are when I was a student here and I
was considering an academic career one
of my mentors told me my life would be
rich he could not have been more right
the joy you brought me to watch your
class grow and flourish over these four
years has made me richer than I could
have ever imagined our days together
were long and arduous but no matter what
you greeted me with smiling faces and
you showed me tremendous gratitude and
respect you put your trust in me and
gave me you're all working with you so
closely allowed me to see what a special
and caring group you are I heard you
give words of support and encouragement
to one another when it was needed most I
witnessed acts of kindness on
basis this is what defines you as a
class and this is what I hope will
define you in the future I wish nothing
more for you than to have lives and
careers that fill you with joy you have
attained real and true skills that will
allow you to heal help and make a
difference in the lives of others use
these skills to leave a lasting mark of
good in the world you already started
this during your time here you traveled
around the world to help those in need
you went into the community which you
called home for the past four years to
educate and to serve continue to do this
and when you reach out to help others
have high standards as people to strive
to their greatest potential and show
them how to do that if I gave you advice
I would tell you to be grateful for the
many blessings in your lives build a
life in which you are generous model you
should model yourself after people that
are kind and unselfish and spirit
remember that you have the ability to
choose how you will react in Coke even
when times are tough all stages of life
bring new adversity you will be judged
by how you respond in the toughest
situations these are the times where
does most challenging but also most
important to be honest and true to
yourselves you do not know exactly where
your lives will take you but I can
guarantee that you you have set
yourselves up for them to take you
beyond your greatest expectations I will
miss you class of 2011 but I will not be
sad because i know you will carry what
you were taught here with you and touch
the lives of so many people in positive
ways and this makes me proud to have
been called your teacher I will leave
you with words you may remember from a
classic childhood story oh the places
you'll go you'll be on your way up
you'll be seeing great sights you'll joy
you'll join the high fliers who soar to
HIGH heights you won't lag behind
because you'll have the speed you'll
pass the whole gang and you
soon take the lead wherever you fly
you'll be best of the best my dear sweet
class of 2011 you did it congratulations
thank you all for coming this evening
congratulations to the class of 2011 for
your academic achievements and all you
have done in these past four years to
enrich this institution we are grateful
to you for that we will we ask all of
you to join us at a reception in the
back of the auditorium right after this
we want to thank delta dental and
eastern dentists Insurance Corporation
for sponsoring that and these
proceedings are completed thank you for
coming